JULIA: Hello everyone, welcome.
My name's Julia, I'm part
of the food team here.
I'm very excited to
welcome our guest chef
today, Alice Medrich,
to the teaching kitchen
here at Google.
Alice is an award-winning
cookbook author.
She is a dessert chef, a
chocolatier, a teacher.
She got her start when she
opened a dessert and chocolate
shop in Berkeley in the '70s.
One of her claims
to fame-- let's
say-- is introducing the
chocolate truffle that we all
know and love to America,
so thank you for that.
Alice is here today
showing some recipes
from her newest book,
"Flavor Flours," which
is her 10th cookbook.
And it was the recipient
of the Best New Cookbook
Award from the James
Beard Foundation
last year in the Desert
and Baking category.
So thank you so much for
being here today, Alice.
We're very excited to
have you, and welcome.
ALICE MEDRICH: Thank you.
I'm going to start out
with this yogurt tart.
It's a 9 1/2 inch tart pan.
This dough that we're about
to make is fairly sticky,
and so just in case
I've greased it--
I've greased it thoroughly,
but not heavily.
So I just want it-- especially
in these little crenelated
areas, because we really want
it to release and be beautiful.
So I've taken the
time to do that.
You can do it with
softened butter,
you can do that with
spray if you like spray.
Or you can do it
with oil, whatever
is going to get it greasy.
Also, when it comes time
to picking equipment,
I personally love a
pan that's not dark.
Because with a pan that's
got this finish on it,
you can get even browning
and it won't brown too fast
on the outside before
the inside is done.
And one of the key
things about whole grains
is they taste better
when they're fully baked
and you get a little toastiness.
So starting with the crust,
I've got oat flour and sugar
and a little rice flour.
The rice flour acts as a sort
of neutral ingredient that
highlights the oats, stretches
them out a little bit.
A teeny, teeny
bit of baking soda
to give a lightness
to the dough.
A little salt.
I like having a group that isn't
scared of a scale, so 85 grams.
You know, the American bakers
have taken a really long time
to get used to the scale.
85 grams-- this is almost.
Didn't get-- just 3 tablespoons
of cream cheese, sorry.
So before I drop
in the wet stuff,
let's just mix it all around.
The idea of mixing the dry
before adding the gooey stuff
is to make sure that the salt
and the soda and anything
that's strong like
that doesn't end up
in one place in the
tart pan, right?
So usually we whisk up
the dry ingredients,
and some of these flours
clump a little bit.
OK, just eyeball me the
3 tablespoons of that.
Baking is very precise,
we don't eyeball at all.
Nope, no eyeballing.
So this pastry could be made in
the food processor or by hand,
but we don't want to
watch the food processor
and we don't want to
have it buzzing away
in this whole demonstration.
So as long as you start with
soft butter and soft cream
cheese, it's really
easy to mix by hand.
And it's also a good
demonstration of the fact
that because we don't have
any gluten-- it's not a wheat
flour-- there's no danger.
If you make pastry,
you know-- thanks.
I think-- is this enough?
Let me see if I got
the amount right.
Is it about 3 tablespoons?
2 tablespoons, good.
OK, so it doesn't matter
how much we handle this.
Because when you handled
a wheat flour pastry,
there's a risk of getting
tough and cardboardy.
Without any gluten, it
just doesn't matter.
So I'm just going to squish
and mash this together.
Like I said, if you don't
like to get your hands dirty
use the food processor, but this
just seems like an easier way
to go.
AUDIENCE: Was that
vanilla extract?
ALICE MEDRICH: Yeah, it
was vanilla, thank you.
Vanilla.
So it's a little cream
cheese, a little butter, salt,
the two flours.
The oat flour is going to
give a lot of flavor here.
In this book-- unlike
other gluten-free books--
I'm not using this all-purpose
gluten-free flour blend.
It's all about highlighting
and celebrating
the flavors of the actual
interesting flours.
So in the oat
chapter you're going
to have a whole lot of things
with oats-- oat flour or oats--
and sometimes the oat flour
will be a single flour
and sometimes it'll be
paired with something.
In this case, paired
with rice, and rice
is like the supporting cast.
So as soon as this is all
mooshed and mashed together--
who's made pastry before
and lined a tart crust?
This is like nothing
you've ever done before
if you've done that before.
Does this look
like-- this doesn't
look like any pastry, doesn't
look like a tart pastry.
That's the beginning of it, OK.
So let's just get
it off my hands.
So obviously we can't roll this
out and fit it into the pan.
So usually we call
this a press-in crust,
but this is really actually
more of a smear-in crust, right?
You can see that.
It's very good to be
able to demonstrate this
because sometimes-- for
somebody who's used to baking,
to describe this is harder
than-- once you see it,
you get it completely.
So you do with your
hands whatever it
takes to get this spread out.
And it looks like not
enough crust, right?
It looks like not enough, but
it is exactly the right amount.
So you aren't going to
have any extra trimmings
or anything like that.
Your job is to get
this pressed everywhere
in here and up the
sides as evenly
as possible-- and with whatever
it takes to do that job.
I kind of challenge
myself when I
make this to do this as
perfectly and evenly as
possible.
Because as I said, when you're
working with whole grains
you want whatever
pastry or cookie
or whatever you're making
to be fully-toasted.
And if the crust is
uneven, the thin places
are going to get
over-baked before I get
that full toasting on the rest.
So like I said, I make
it sort of a project
to get this as smooth
and even as possible.
And one trick is to realize
that a lot of the extra dough
tends to hide in the corners.
So if you think you
don't have enough dough,
push your fingers in
the corner and you're
going to find a whole lot more.
And when you've got too much
on one side, put it elsewhere.
The real truth is I shorted
the butter on this because we
didn't have it, so now I've
got that bigger challenge
of making a teeny bit less
of this go a little further.
But it's still
going to go there.
And the other thing
I want here is
to make sure that this
upper-top edge is squared off.
I don't want it tapering
up against the pan side,
because that's going to burn
before everything gets baked.
So if you liked playing with
clay or Play-Doh as a kid,
this is your thing.
I mean, there are
other pressing crusts
that are thicker
and more forgiving,
and you can just-- This one
is a little bit more finicky
than that.
So just when you think you can't
possibly make this any better,
there is a great trick.
We're making it
close to perfect,
and I'll get to
that in a second.
OK, so here's the
rest of the procedure.
So this is not to wrap it up,
this is to kind of line it.
So I'm going to press
it across the bottom
and into those
corners, and then I'm
going to finish smoothing this
by tearing off a piece of paper
towel-- and finding
something that's got
a nice square edge like this.
And I'm just going to use it
to press into the corners,
smooth out the bottom, and
this gets into the corners
so I'm not going to have a
big, chunky, inelegant corner.
And why do I have the
paper towel in here?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: The plastic is sticky.
ALICE MEDRICH: The plastic is
sticky, you can't slide this.
So this can make
even what started out
to be a pretty rough, pretty
smooth and pretty even.
And you can go back
and fix up this edge.
This type of crust,
this type of dough,
and many of these whole
grain doughs benefit
from at least a couple
hours of rest if possible,
or an overnight rest.
So now you've got not only a
pretty perfectly even crust,
but it's all wrapped
for the fridge, OK?
AUDIENCE: Are we
supposed to hydrate it?
ALICE MEDRICH: And
to hydrate it, yes.
That rest also-- thank
you-- hydrates it.
Which is good, because when
especially the whole grains get
hydrated, then they bake better.
They bake more
fully and you don't
get that sort of gritty,
tongue-biting effect
that you get from an
undercooked whole grain.
And you may not even know
what I'm talking about,
but if you've experimented
with this kind of stuff
you've probably made a lot of
tongue-biting, gritty things.
This will not be that.
You can bake this right away
or you can refrigerate it.
We happen to have
baked one, so I'm
going to show you
what that looks like.
This can just go away.
But anyway, I've gone for
really into the corners,
straight up the sides,
and squared off.
And whatever it
takes to do that,
I spent the time to do it.
So either give it
a rest or bake it.
So it goes into the oven at 325.
For those of you who
bake, that sounds
really low for a tart pastry.
These whole grain and other
grain tart pastries and cookies
tend to like to bake
longer and slower.
It gives it more time in the
oven to get fully baked, get
that hydrated dough
fully-baked at a lower
temperature for longer.
I tried when I did
these recipes-- I tried
350, 375, 325, and I compared.
I'm not a scientist,
but I do know
that if you do something long
enough-- if a monkey types long
enough, a sentence might appear.
So anyway this is baked,
it goes in the oven
for about 15 minutes,
and sometimes
it poofs up a little bit.
At about the 15-minute mark
you can either press it down
with the back of a fork, and if
it's lost a little bit of shape
you can actually
cheat and take the cup
that you used to shape it
and just kind of press it
in the corners to
reestablish shape.
And so when it's
fully baked, it should
have some really nice color.
A pale pastry
doesn't have flavor,
and especially when we're
talking about a whole grain.
You want color.
This probably
took-- I don't know,
the recipe says 25, 35,
40-- whatever it says.
Then it comes out and
I painted it already
with a little bit of
egg yolk and salt.
I painted it, put it back
in the oven for 2 minutes,
and the purpose of
that is just to seal it
because we're going to put
a wet filling in there.
And also notice that this
is a pre-baked shell,
but it's not partially-baked.
Even though we're putting
a filling in there
and it's going to go back in
the oven for 15 or 20 minutes,
it's not going to get
any further baked.
So don't think you're
trying to partially bake.
That's a big, big
fault in baking--
the idea of partially-baked
shells is usually wrong.
You need to fully bake even
if it's going to go back in,
because the filling will
prevent it from further baking.
So filling-- I
love this filling.
I've done this filling
with sour cream,
I've done it with yogurt--
which we're doing today.
This is like a yogurt custard.
It eats and feels like really
light, smooth cheesecake,
only with a tang and
less fat and really
a beautiful suave
kind of texture.
And it starts with 3
eggs, and into that
goes a little sugar,
salt, and vanilla.
OK, a weird and interesting
fact-- and I thought about this
before I came here because I
thought, one of those Googlers
is going to ask
me why this is so,
and I'm not sure I can
answer the question.
But in this recipe,
the smoothest filling
is going to be
gotten by whisking
the yogurt into the eggs,
not the eggs into the yogurt.
And it has something to do
with the way things emulsify
and which particular
type of emulsion this is.
And I don't think I can go
further in the conversation
than that, it's not my area.
But anyway, I do know
for a fact that it's
one into the other instead
of the other into one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALICE MEDRICH: I'm
trying to remember
what this recipe called for.
It's over there if you want to
look, the recipe is specific.
But it's plain
unsweetened yogurt,
and I'm sure that
I've done it with--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALICE MEDRICH: This is Greek?
Is that what the
recipe calls for?
Good.
That's what the recipe calls
for, that's what we've got.
OK, so plain Greek yogurt.
And I do go for
pretty pure yogurt,
I don't like a lot of additives.
I just like the cultured stuff--
just the culturing stuff,
I don't like any
gelatin in there.
So let's get all of--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALICE MEDRICH: I
was about to say,
I think I've done this with all
levels and it's probably fine.
It's not like a little
more-- you know,
the difference between full-fat
yogurt and low-fat yogurt
is very little.
And eggs are rich.
I just don't think
that fat is going
to make a structural problem,
meaning the recipe won't work.
It may taste a
little differently.
When you lower the
fat a little, you
get a little more tanginess--
which I actually don't
mind in a recipe like this.
So anyway, this is
really nice and smooth.
And normally you'd
mix this together
while the tart's
baking and let it sit.
The tart comes out of
the oven, it's hot,
you brush on the egg
wash, it goes back
into the oven for 2
minutes, remember?
And it's still hot--
pretend it's still hot.
I should use the gloves, right?
And then this sort of
beautiful ivory-colored yogurt
custard gets poured on
there, and it goes back.
In the meantime, you will have
turned the oven down to 300.
And you're just going
to let this custard cook
at this really low temperature,
300 degrees, until--
and I actually am going
to put it in the oven--
until when you shake it
in the pan like this,
it jiggles like Jello.
But not stiff Jello,
kind of lazy Jello,
like it's starting to set
but it's not rigid yet.
And that makes the
difference between something
quite gorgeous and wonderful
to eat and something less so.
I am going to stick
this into the oven.
And if this tart were
hot as it should be,
the time it takes in the
oven is somewhere between-- I
don't know-- 10, 15, 20.
It kind of depends on
your oven, and you're
going to be looking at it
every now and then, giving it
a little nudge to
see how it quivers.
So I was going to ask if
there's questions about that.
Were there questions about
that or should we save them?
Should I go on?
I'll go on.
So the next recipe
that I wanted to do
is this little
gingerbread, which
is made with the
Cuisinart food processor.
I love gingerbread, I
also like buckwheat flour.
This flour here is going to be
buckwheat flour and brown rice
flour.
So it's totally whole
grain, except for the fact
that-- I'm going
to let you do this
because I'm fumbling with this.
Totally whole grain
except for the fact
that buckwheat
isn't a true grain,
it's called a pseudo-cereal.
It acts like a grain and
it looks like a grain,
but it's actually neither
a grain nor a grass.
But anyway, we're going to
treat it like a grain here.
And we're going to start
out with the brown rice.
And again, we're going to
give that little pre-mix thing
so everything gets put together.
Although since it
goes in the processor,
I wonder why we're doing that.
Brown rice, salt, a little
baking soda, powdered ginger,
and all spice and cinnamon.
And a tiny bit of xanthan gum.
Who's worked with xanthan gun?
OK, a tiny bit.
Because there's no
wheat, there's no gluten,
there's no structure-producing
proteins in this cake,
we're using a little xanthan.
It makes things a little sticky,
it makes them hold together,
it's going to give
you a cakier texture,
it keeps things
from falling apart.
And it gets used in a lot
of gluten-free baking.
In this book, I
made a big effort
to find all the ways I could
do a lot of recipes without it.
Some people don't
like to use it.
I think eating too much of it
is not necessarily a good idea--
not because it can harm
you, but because it's
sort of like cement.
It pulls things together, and a
lot of the gluten-free recipes
out there use so much
of it that you end up
with this sort of
cement lump in here.
So in the experimentation
for this book, any time
we needed to use
xanthan gum, we kept
decreasing the amount
to see at what level
we were getting the
effect we wanted.
And if we lost that effect,
we'd increase a little bit.
So we cut this way, way down to
about a quarter of a teaspoon.
And sometimes then we
just took it all out
to make sure that
we really needed it.
In this case, we did.
So there's just a little
bit of it in there.
In addition to the powdered
ginger, I've got fresh ginger.
And if you've not worked
with fresh ginger before,
it smells wonderful and
pungent and fantastic.
And it's easiest to
peel with a rounded
spoon, the edge of a spoon.
Or you can use a
vegetable peeler.
We're just going to
use 30 grams of this,
so I might throw
it on the scale.
I gave an elaborate way to
measure it without a scale.
This book has measurements
all in volume and grams.
I think it's a
good thing to use.
If you've got grams
or ounces, do that
and use that instead
of the volume--
especially with dry ingredients
and especially with flours.
Every time you touch flour--
every time you move it
from one container to
the next, every time
you pour it, every
time you touch it-- you
change how much of
it fits in a cup.
So there's no way to know how
much you are putting in a cup
compared to how much
you're putting in a cup
or you're putting in a cup.
Because first of all, everybody
packs the cup differently
and everybody's handled
the flour differently.
So if we're all working with
the same ounces or grams,
at least that removes one of the
variables that can make things
go wrong.
So when you're working
with fresh ginger--
even though I'm
going to puree it--
I want to reduce the
amount of stringiness.
So the fibers are
running this way,
so I'm going to cut
it in thin pieces
to cut across those
stringing grains.
This is for any time
you're going to be chopping
or pureeing or what have you.
So we're doing-- let's see, on.
I had a whole
tutorial-- now it's off.
OK.
It's teared, OK, good enough.
OK, so we're going for 30--
it's changing a lot here.
That's it, that's it.
All right.
So the food processor, the
ginger with the brown sugar,
and if we leave that
on for a few seconds
it's going to turn into puree.
So even if you're doing a
dish that gets chopped ginger,
if you slice across the
grain first before you
chop you're going to reduce
the amount of stringiness
that you get in there.
Good little tip.
When you're doing savory
cooking, some of that
doesn't matter.
You're just cutting a coin
and putting it in the wok
or whatever and getting flavor.
The same is true
about a peeling.
A lot of savory cooks--
especially Asian chefs--
won't peel ginger.
Other people do, some
people don't, but I
think for something
like dessert I
don't want the peels in there.
So here's the puree.
I'm going to melt some butter--
forgot that here, there's
a little bit of melted butter.
Pan preparation is important,
and different recipes
seem to require a different
kind of pan preparation.
Sometimes it's
grease, sometimes it's
grease and flour-- it all
depends on what kind of surface
you want or how that
particular batter releases
from the side of the cake.
So I'm not a one-prep-suits-all
recipe person.
Every one of my cakes has a
different pan preparation.
I sometimes have to look
at the recipe myself
to get reminded what I've
chosen because there's usually
a good reason for it.
No matter what I
do, however, there's
always a circle of parchment
paper on the bottom.
That ensures that no
matter what, this cake
is coming out of the pan
because you can always
release the sides.
And if you can release the
sides and flip it out--
because if the
sides are stick, you
can always run a spatula
around that no problem,
but you can't do anything
about the bottom.
But if you've got
paper there, you always
have a way to get the cake out.
Some chefs and cooking
teachers will grease the pan,
put in the parchment, and
then grease the parchment.
Really?
That, to me, just is overkill.
I just put the paper in there,
put the cake batter in there,
when the cake comes out the
paper's attached to the cake,
I peel it off the cake.
That saves me a whole
lot of fooling around.
OK, we do have hot butter now.
So the pre-mixed flour is
going into the puree here.
This was the brown rice flour
with the salt and leavening
and spices.
AUDIENCE: So where do you
source your flours from?
ALICE MEDRICH: I buy
some from Bob's Red Mill.
I like also Authentic Foods,
which I have to get online.
The reason I like Authentic
Foods is because the flours
that they make, they're finer.
They make brown rice, white
rice, sorghum, and corn.
And they're just a
little bit finer,
so it gives you some
more opportunities
to get really refined textures
even out of whole grains.
And that's-- I think-- really
part of the fun of doing
something in a desert with
whole grains where people
don't expect them.
And having them turn out
refined and elegant as opposed
to hippie rustic-- which
I also like, but OK.
So the molasses goes
in here, and the egg,
and the butter-- which I hope
is not too hot to cook the egg,
so I'll pour it over here.
Warm butter was called
for, but this'll be fine.
Now maybe you're wondering
why this rest of this flour
isn't going in here.
There's a weird tricky thing
going on with this recipe--
easy to mix.
Because of the
xanthan gum, I'm going
to just blend this-- when I
find the top-- about 15 seconds.
If I over-blend
it, at some point
that gum is going
to lose its hold.
And I'm not actually sure
how many seconds out that is.
So when I say mix for 20
seconds or 15 seconds,
I kind of want you
to watch the clock.
Can somebody do that?
Oh, we've got that
many millisecond, huh?
That's slow.
Done?
So then the other
tricky part of this--
there's the xanthan which
I don't want to over-mix,
and then there's the
buckwheat flour which
has a really weird property.
If you mix it-- even
in a pan or even
if you're cooking it as porridge
and you mix it too much--
it goes to complete
mush, like cement.
Anybody done that?
Yeah?
So I don't want that in there
the whole for 15 seconds,
I want it in at the very end.
And it goes in with a little
bit of hot water, which
I'm going to measure in this
wonderful little pre-measured
thing that we marked.
So hot water from
the tap is fine.
And it's a half a cup.
We didn't have a
little cup measure,
so we marked off a thing.
So hot water and the
buckwheat, and I'm
just going to give it
like five seconds just
to blend it in there.
Like I said, quirky
little procedures
for some of this, using some
of these different flours.
So it's a very liquid batter,
I've made muffins and cupcakes
out of it.
The pan called for in the
recipe is 8-inch and this is 9.
Normally I'm a stickler
for the right size pan,
but this just means that it's
going to bake in less time,
right?
It's thinner, it's going
to bake in less time.
So the buckwheat turned out to
be one of the most interesting
of all of the not-grains
that I worked with.
I worked with a co-author
who lives in Portland,
and you might
wonder how you could
do a collaboration like this
with somebody so far away.
We had worked together for many
years, she knows my palate,
I know her palate,
and we suddenly
discovered-- this
goes in the oven,
and that's all there
is to it, really.
We suddenly discovered
at a certain point
when I was in a jam
with a book deadline--
and I thought since
she'd moved away
we could never work again--
I called her up and I said,
I'm in deep doo-doo,
what are you doing?
She said, not so much right now.
I said, could you try
this and this, and what
do you think about this?
And we found out that
we could work together
after all of those years.
So when this book came
along, I knew that we
could do this at long distance.
Because we think
alike and differently.
There's a great
overlap and yet we
have some of the same
problem-solving skills.
So we're working on buckwheat,
which we both like a lot.
And she's doing a whole
one set of recipes,
and I'm doing another,
but all with buckwheat.
We're exploring
buckwheat, we're trying
to figure out what buckwheat
will do and how it tastes
and what the texture is.
And I call her up one day-- we
have these long, long check-in
collaboration
meetings on the phone.
I call her up one day
and I say, oh my God, I'm
getting these beautiful,
floral, fragrant, light flavors
and textures unlike anything.
I mean, if you've eaten
buckwheat before it's
pretty earthy, right?
It's kasha, it's soba, it's
not gentle and it's not floral.
So I said I'm so excited about
all these flavors and textures.
She said well, that's good
because I'm getting cement
here.
And we're talking about
this, she's getting cement,
nothing is tasting good, and
we talk and talk and talk.
And then we go away,
we get off the phone,
we haven't solved
anything, and she
decides that it's the
fineness of the flour that's
causing a problem and giving
her these mushy, cement-like
textures.
So she goes off and buys some
buckwheat in the bulk bin,
and grinds it up
to a course meal,
and makes her cake
all over again.
And it is suddenly fantastic.
I, in the meantime, am
thinking more and more
about what's happening
to her and why
it isn't happening to me.
And I re-stumble on information
that when you stir buckwheat
too much, you get mush.
And I realize the
cake she's working on
takes a lot of beating,
it's just that kind of case.
It's like a butter
cake, lots of beating.
The cakes I'm working on are
sponge cakes-- gentle folding.
So of course she's
getting mush and I'm
getting-- because she's
activating the mush factor.
But in the meantime, we both
came to different solutions
to the same problem.
It made that chapter one of the
most interesting in the book
because there's a lot
of different textures
and different kinds of
recipes using buckwheat.
Because of that whole problem
solving-- the way in which
we're both the
same and different.
It was really one of the
best parts of collaborating.
I have done what
I came here to do.
At least in terms
of baking, are there
questions or
comments or anywhere
you want to go with this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How long do these
flours last in the cupboard?
ALICE MEDRICH: Oh yeah.
A lot of them are
whole grain, so you
would treat them like you
would treat whole wheat.
And if you use
them all the time,
don't buy more than you can use
in a certain amount of time.
I look at the sell-by
dates, because nobody
can sell a flour that's going
to go bad the next-- you know,
you've got two or three or four
months after the sell-by date
if it's packaged.
Longer if it's in the fridge or
in the freezer-- I do sort of
address this in the book, too.
People are always asking this,
and it's kind of a best guess.
I mean, you should learn
to sniff the flours
when you open a bag.
Especially when
it's fresh, it gets
you used to what fresh flour
smells like-- so that when
it goes rancid, you'll know.
But yeah, you have
longer than you think.
And if you're using
something that you're not
using very often,
maybe the freezer
is the best place to put that.
One of the things that's
fun about this book
is you don't have
to go out and buy
all these flours to begin with.
You can start out
with-- like if you're
interested in the buckwheat,
get the buckwheat flour
and get some rice flour,
and you can practically
do everything in that
chapter with either buckwheat
alone or buckwheat and rice.
There's a couple of
dog legs from there,
but you can explore
them flour by flour.
Somebody else?
AUDIENCE: I have a quick one.
ALICE MEDRICH: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned a lot
that the buckwheat gets really
concrete and terrible,
and honestly I'm
intrigued why that might be?
And I know you hate
those why questions--
ALICE MEDRICH: No,
I love the whys.
I love the whys when they're
something I can answer.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ALICE MEDRICH: I
don't actually know.
We sort of went right
into problem-solving mode
and didn't stop and say
well, why is that happening?
I don't know.
But if anybody
ever makes kasha--
does anybody make kasha?
Did anybody grow up with kasha?
A beloved and detested
Jewish-Russian
dish that some of us grew
up with and some of us liked
and some of us did not.
There's a step in there
where you take the grain
and you toast it in the
pan coated with some egg,
and then you steam it like rice.
And I think that
coating with egg
helps to prevent those little
particles from becoming mushy.
But the last time
I saw that made
was so long ago-- when
I was probably a kid--
and I don't remember that.
So I never researched
that mushy thing.
AUDIENCE: And does it do
anything to the flavor?
ALICE MEDRICH: Which?
What?
AUDIENCE: The over-stirring
the buckwheat.
ALICE MEDRICH: Well,
you know, if it's
going to take-- I'm a big
believer that texture affects
flavor.
Because if you're
eating something
that feels like cement in your
mouth, you're not likely--
Does it do something to flavor?
Maybe not necessarily.
Although in the case of what
she made, it certainly did.
Because those lovely
floral fragrant
flavors didn't come out until
she had something light.
So perhaps, yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you speak
to some of the nutritional
differences between these whole
grains and whole wheat flour?
ALICE MEDRICH: I
can say in general,
the reason we like
whole grains is
that there's some nutritional
value in there, right?
There's the heart-healthy
aspect of it--
it's good for cholesterol, it's
got fiber, it's got protein.
And in general when we're
talking about whole grains,
we're comparing them
with refined grains
where they've taken away
the fiber coating, the--
what is it?
The bran and the germ which
has got the protein in it.
So specifically
compared to whole wheat,
I'd have to look it up.
And you can probably look
those things up flour by flour,
and they probably all
differ a little bit.
Yeah, I don't know if that
got close to an answer, but--
AUDIENCE: More
benefits [INAUDIBLE].
ALICE MEDRICH: More
benefits, yeah.
And my goal here was not
to make healthy food,
my goal was to--
because I'm a chef,
I'm all about the delicious.
And I also like the
unexpected, and I'm
sort of open to different
flavors and textures.
And I love the flavor of whole
grains-- in cereals, in breads,
and all of those things--
and it's intriguing to me
to bring it into the world of
pastry because it's unexpected.
And it's not that I'm
trying to hide it,
it's not the stealth
thing where I'm
trying to trick the kids
into eating their peas.
It's just because that's
my sort of creative drive,
to make something delicious
in an unexpected way.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned in
the book chestnut flour--
sourcing it and being able to
find a source that does not
have a smoky quality to it.
What causes the smoky
quality, is it like rice?
ALICE MEDRICH: They roast or
dry them over some form of fire
that's got smoke.
And it may even be
something that's
liked in Italy, because
I think the Italians tend
to have a bit of that
smoke-- but not all of them.
I just don't find that
delicious for all the desert
things that I made.
And I did find an American
source-- two of them, actually.
One of them-- especially
good-- Allen Creek Farms,
that you can buy online some
chestnut flour from in season.
And it's only sort of seasonal.
Yeah, another?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ALICE MEDRICH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you have a favorite flour?
ALICE MEDRICH: I
love the buckwheat.
And by the way, this
gingerbread is more
on the sort of robust
and earthy flavor side,
not on the fragrant,
floral side.
I love the buckwheat for all
the different things it does.
I'm crazy about corn flour.
I mean, everybody knows
what cornbread is,
but as soon as you have flour
that's finer than cornmeal
you can make a chiffon
cake out of it that
is golden and beautiful,
and really quite delicious.
So I love the corn.
And the oats, to me,
taste a little bit
like-- have a
caramely note to it.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a follow-up to that,
which is were there
any flours that you
tried that were just completely
unsuitable for baking?
ALICE MEDRICH: No, we kind
of honed on these ones
pretty quickly,
because between us we
kind of knew what we liked.
I like the flavor
of millet flour--
and I would use that next,
if there's any follow-up.
I love the flavor of millet,
but every now and then millet
gets really bitter in my mouth,
and I never did solve that.
And we quickly moved
onto some other flours
that we agreed we
wanted to work with,
so poor millet got left behind.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is
there any benefit
in milling your own grains
as opposed to buying flour?
ALICE MEDRICH:
People say-- and I'm
sure that this is true--
that if you mill your own,
you get this amazing,
amazing flour.
I know that bread
bakers believe that,
and I'm sure that it's true.
And it would be probably true
for what I've done here, too.
Because the agenda in
this book was so big,
we decided not to just go
over there and do that, too.
But I started to
experiment a little bit
with that after I
published the book,
to see what the
great fuss was about.
And I found that no
matter what I did,
I couldn't get flours as fine
as the commercially-milled ones.
And it's not that I want
everything to be really fine
and fluffy-- you'll
see that these are not
particularly fine and fluffy.
But I really value having
some of these grains
in a really fine flour form.
So I didn't follow-up
too, too much.
Has anybody milled their own?
AUDIENCE: I've been trying some
things inspired by your book
actually--
ALICE MEDRICH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --on trying
different grains
and going through a bunch
of them, but some of it's
been to experiment
with mochi making.
ALICE MEDRICH: With what making?
AUDIENCE: Mochi making.
ALICE MEDRICH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --and just trying to
find some balance with that.
But in general, I just
kind of like the idea
of being able to try textures.
I knew that I probably wouldn't
be able to get it as fine,
but--
ALICE MEDRICH: I
mean, sometimes you
want a coarser texture, right?
I mean, the buckwheat thing that
she did was good proof of that.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering if you
could go through one of
the creative processes
of your recipes--
maybe a favorite one?
I'm curious of how
these things come about.
ALICE MEDRICH: So when
I started this project,
I actually knew very
little about these flours.
I had done a few little
things with these flours
in conjunction with
wheat, and I knew
I was interested in
the flavor because I
knew that they were
enhancing to the things
that I did with wheat.
And I really hadn't done much
without any wheat at all.
So I was starting with that
blank slate kind of thing,
with this great
idea and I thought
there might be a book in this.
And I also knew that there was
a great advantage to coming
at something without having
been fully-steeped in it,
educated in it, trained
in it-- because then you
get trained in the way.
And I knew I didn't want to do
it the way that it was being
done, because I hadn't tasted
anything very tasty the way
it had been done.
So it was a blank slate.
And the first thing
I thought of was how
am I going to get structure?
Do we always have
to use xanthan gum?
And I thought, I wonder if a
recipe that's heavy in eggs
and that gets its
structure from eggs
anyway might work with these
flours without any gum?
And so I had the most
amazing beginner's luck.
A few weeks before, a freelance
writer from "The Wall Street
Journal" called up and
she said, can I come?
I'm writing a story
about creative process.
Can I come and follow
you around for a day?
And I thought, oh my God,
what will I do with this one?
I thought OK, I'll do some of
my experiments for this project.
I'll invite her and
if they work, fine.
If they don't, it's part
of the creative process.
So she comes over,
and my idea is
to take a really basic,
easy French sponge
cake-- five ingredients, I could
do it in my sleep really fast--
and test the idea of
whether a sponge cake that
gets its structure
from egg could
work with all of these flours.
And in front of her-- or
maybe I did some in advance--
but I picked about five flours
and I made this sponge cake,
and they all worked.
They all worked.
Maybe some of them needed a
little tweak here and there,
but clearly the structure
from the eggs-- and that
led me to thinking--
it also gave me
a way to taste these grains
as single grains in each cake.
I did blend or anything.
And it also led me to think
OK, any time a recipe already
has enough eggs in
it to give structure,
these grains might work.
These flours might work.
So it let me the whole
family of sponge cakes, which
includes chiffon
cakes-- anything that
is powered by eggs.
And on Maya's side of the
ledger up there in Portland,
she had been realizing that
recipes that had eggs--
if you start out by
beating them a lot,
you get more
structure from them.
So it was like one
thing led to another.
There were some dead
ends-- and I can't even
remember what some of
those were right now--
but there were some
really good lucky breaks.
AUDIENCE: Can you say how much
work's involved in something--
a book like this?
ALICE MEDRICH: Never made so
many bad pastries in my life.
AUDIENCE: I know.
Do you have assistants or
do you do all the cooking?
ALICE MEDRICH: No, she
and I did it ourselves.
AUDIENCE: That's impressive.
ALICE MEDRICH: You sort
of can't afford assistants
if you're really
just a book writer.
If you have a whole day job
and a whole business going on
on the side, it's
a little different.
But even for a Cocolat,
I did it myself.
I did it myself because it was
meant to be for a home cook,
and you can't apply what
goes on in a bakery to what
goes on in a home kitchen.
JULIE: So thanks everyone
for coming out today.
And I want to especially
extend a thank you to Alice
for being here,
sharing her expertise,
sharing these recipes.
So thank you again.
ALICE MEDRICH: Thank you.